Hi, welcome back to the show. Let's walk through the solution for this one
because it's just a little bit tricky. First, we need to keep some sort of
count on how many of the assets have been loaded and how many we're waiting to
load. To do this, we create a nifty little object here, that has a count that
represents how many objects have been loaded, a total which is how many objects
we're waiting to load, and then the given call back function. Now we want to
take our code, which previously only loaded one asset and issued a call back,
and add loop around it so that we can do this for the entire asset list. Now,
there's one tricky thing here, is that once we actually load an object and get
a call back function for it, we want to do some logic before we issue the call
back. So for instance once the first image is loaded, we don't want to issue
the call back then, we want to wait until the entire set has been loaded. For
this, we added the new function called onLoadedCallback. This function, given
an asset that's been loaded, will actually go through and increase the count on
the batch. Once our count equals that total number of assets we're waiting for,
we actually issue the callback at that time. With this setup, you have the
ability to issue a batch of assets, load them, and when they've all been
loaded, you finally get your callback.